let me tell you a little bit about my
personal journey to silicon valley from
india
22 years ago growing up in india
like many of you i got my first
telephone when i was 12.
in my case it turned out to be a rotary
phone so it wasn't that great for
selfies
but i still love to call my friends play
with it
and sometimes take it apart that
telephone
cemented my fascination with technology
i remember
in my parents house in chennai reading
about the invention of the transistor at
bell labs
of course that initial invention helped
found
what became known as silicon valley and
out of that
came companies like fragile
semiconductor and intel
and all the computers and software that
we all use today
you can draw a direct line from that
invention
to the technology that powers your
twitter feed or your wechat messages
today
i remember reading about that and
thinking it's the idea that matters
it didn't matter where you come from or
what your background is
one revolutionary idea one brilliant
invention
can unleash other entrepreneurs to
revolutionize industries in base
you could never predict
i think it's important to remember uh
you know
uh getting into an elite institution
doesn't guarantee success
uh it matters a lot but it doesn't
guarantee success and
uh you know i think i think it's
important to keep that perspective in
life and
uh you know life's a long road and
you know so you want to you want to take
it at the right pace and enjoy what
you're doing
it's important to remember uh there are
many many different ways
uh you know you can approach things and
what matters most is
you know loving what you're doing and
and trying to do well at it
a lot of times when i was younger you
know people would say you know this
person didn't get into this college or
something and that's the end of the road
i mean life is so
different from that and so i think it's
important to
you know keep your hopes keep keep your
dreams and try to follow them and you
know i think
i think most of how life plays out is up
to you
not up to up to what happens outside of
you and i think it's important to keep
that in mind and take the long-term view
[Music]
you know when you're when you're trying
to run something at the scale of google
you know we have now over 60 000 people
and uh you know i
you rely on other strong leaders i think
you know a lot of what i do is
you know i have an outstanding
leadership team
it's learning to let go and really
empowering people
you know at all levels of the
organization and you know trusting them
to
doing the right thing and as a leader a
lot of your job is to make
those people successful it's less less
about trying to be successful and more
about
making sure you have good people and
your
your work is to remove barriers remove
roadblocks for them
so that they can be successful in what
they do and so that's how i've always
thought about it
you know also valued uh you know
teamwork quite a bit
and you know i think it's really
important to build organizations where
people actually want to work together
you know everything comes out of that so
setting up collaborative
cultures is another big thing i'd really
focus on
[Music]
the long arc of history tells us we have
every reason to be hopeful
so be hopeful there are probably things
about technology
that frustrate you and make you
impatient
don't lose that impatience he'll create
the next technology revolution
and enable you to build things my
generation could never dream of
you may be just as frustrated by my
generation's approach to climate change
or education be impatient
it'll create the progress the world
needs
you will make the world better in your
own way
even if you don't know exactly how the
important thing
is to be open-minded so that you can
find what you love
so take the time to find the thing that
excites you more than
anything else in the world not the thing
your parents want you to do
or the thing that all your friends are
doing or that society expensively
i know you're getting a lot of advice
today so let me leave you with mine
be open be impatient be
hopeful if you can do that history will
remember the class of 2020
not for what you lost but for what you
changed
you have the chance to change everything
i'm optimistic
you will thank you
you